a tweet from G2 Esports founder and CEO
Carlos ocelot Rodriguez has prompted a
fan backlash an apology from his org and
an unpaid eight-week vacation from his
role as CEO the tweet in question showed
Carlos partying with noted controversy
Singularity Andrew Tate yeah
I was stunlocked by this story all
weekend so let's just dive into it
before we get into the video I need to
draw your attention to this hoodie
that's right we've got merged for the
score Esports now and as the resident
hoodie Queen I have to tell you it's
pretty comfy we've got other stuff too
including a great one that says touch
grass which we probably all need the
reminder check it out in the description
below okay so if you're not familiar
with who Andrew Tate is I'd recommend
you check out our original video on this
topic which explains how he broke into
the streaming space and all that fun
stuff but long story short Andrew Tate
has been blowing up on social media
partially because it is often chilling
views on women or money or
even Star Wars particularly though he
had an affiliate program that paid
people for signing up others to his
Hustlers University program things
started to change pretty quickly in late
August when Instagram Facebook Tick Tock
and YouTube all banned him permanently
from their platforms at the time a tick
tock spokesperson told NBC News quote
misogyny is a hateful ideology that is
not tolerated on Tick Tock end quote
while it didn't seem like hate would
just give up it did seem like his
avenues for promoting his message or
whatever were becoming a lot more
limited and as the streaming gaming and
Esports communities beamed on the
announcement of his bands it kind of
felt like maybe it was the end at least
for now instead G2 founder and CEO
Carlos has dragged Tate back into the
spotlight on Saturday ocelot tweeted a
video of himself and both Tape Brothers
at some sort of event with the caption
yesterday we celebrated g2's World
Championship
[Music]
[Applause]
to be clear this was his personal
account and he chose to share this tweet
it's not like he was being spied on or
something people immediately started
posting their reactions to it and while
I want to go over one of the arguments I
saw a lot in those reactions for now
let's just focus on what happened and
the context surrounding it so for
context G2 Esports is an organization
that signed women's rosters invalent and
more recently League of Legends I can't
imagine working for someone who brags
about his very popular friend who thinks
that women should be treated like
property that would certainly affect my
opinion of my employment situation and
that's without even mentioning all the
women who actually work for G2 and other
roles besides those teams that we just
mentioned it's true that Carlos has
always had this chaotic roguish sort of
energy of the guy who will say and do
whatever he wants damn the torp that
sort of thing but at the same time
bragging about partying with Tate
crossed a line for a lot of people the
Relentless dunking continued a reply
seemed inevitable and we finally got one
about 10 hours later
which will probably become an incredible
copy pasta in the future nobody will
ever be able to police my friendships I
draw my light here I party with whoever
the I want
again plenty of dunking on this take
especially given that it through
plausible deniability out the window
because before this tweet Carlos could
have done the old I wasn't sure he would
be there I shouldn't have been in a
video with him I shouldn't have posted
the video it was a mistake whatever you
know the standard kind of like walk it
back PR talk type I'm sure you've seen
it before instead though he doubled down
and called Tate a friend seemingly then
the next day the inevitable hangover
after a full day's rager of righteous
indignation Carlos posted two tweets
which acknowledge the fan reaction said
he got it wrong and that he would accept
the consequences it did fall a bit short
of an actual apology though and it
definitely didn't look like something
Carlos wrote himself at least in my
opinion shortly after that the G2
Esports account tweeted a statement that
did actually include an apology and also
noted that Carlos is going to take eight
weeks of unpaid leave from his position
as CEO as some Twitter users noted
though Carlos continued to like tweets
supporting both himself and Tate he also
weirdly cleared his bio and profile name
on Twitter and changed his Twitter
Avatar to a Phoenix egg so that pretty
much gets you up to speed on where we
are now Tate remains banned Carlos is on
an eight-week sabbatical slash potential
Joker Arc and G2 is apologizing for the
events of this weekend and fans well it
seems like some of them at least have
already decided to move on I'm going to
continue talking about this one argument
that just kept cropping up in the
replies to all of these tweets because
there was some pretty wax
to be honest firstly the whole you can't
police my friendships thing so firstly
in case you forgot Carlos posted this
video it wasn't some kind of lightning
strike by a secretive group of
blue-haired ninja or something if you
post something publicly it's pretty fair
to assume that you either want people to
see it or at the very least you don't
care if they do so clearly Carlos
thought it was funny or that it would
cause people to get upset and he either
wanted that or didn't care if that's
what happened next here's a shocking
fact for you people are allowed to form
opinions based on who other people
affiliate with that's happened pretty
much forever like
it's not new the only real question is
what behaviors do we consider so
unacceptable that affiliating with
someone who does them or who espouses
the view that we should do those things
is a hard line and just to be clear the
people saying that you should never
judge anyone for any relationship with
anyone that they have nobody lives like
that those people absolutely do that
it's just not a real thing it's not a
real thing now you absolutely can and
some people would argue you should have
friendships with people who don't share
your exact belief system or maybe have
entirely different philosophies I
personally do have friends like that
it's good for me it's good for them I
don't regret it and nobody here is
advocating that there should be like an
echo chamber or anything the problem is
when someone's views or actions cross a
line that you can't cross yourself and
for most human beings the humanity of
women and their right to equal treatment
it's not up for debate it's just a deal
breaker and that's frankly okay no one's
saying that you can't be friends with
Andrew Tate you can do whatever you want
when it comes to friendships but people
can also adjust their opinion of you as
a result of that and I don't even
personally think like Carlos espouses
all of the beliefs that Andrew Tate does
I do think that people have a right to
be upset if you promote someone who has
a frankly pretty shocking view of women
lastly I want to address the future
where this all goes from here I imagine
there are a lot of fans doing some soul
searching right now and women working
for the organization who may feel
worried about the current situation how
it will affect their job or maybe even
their future in the Esports industry and
yeah this will definitely affect the
reputation of G2 Esports at least in the
short term
for me as a fan of G2 Esports on and off
for some time they always got bonus
points for keeping my favorite French CS
players employed and I've spoken with so
many of their players over the years and
even Carlos himself and the event
content that they put out like the
videos that they film about their
players attending events
were some of the best in the industry
like straight up respect to be honest
this move just really doesn't feel like
it's in line with the g2 that I thought
I knew and notably Carlos's wife with
whom it seems he's currently separated
came out to defend his track record on
misogyny as well saying that she'd never
seen anything like that from him even
current G2 creators seem to acknowledge
that what happened isn't in line with
g2's own internal philosophy on things
now late on Monday afternoon a report
from 1pv is now revealed that this
controversy may have compromised his
org's chance at a spot in valorence
franchised n a league if true this is a
massive blow to an organization that has
already invested heavily in the esport
and seemed poised to continue that
trajectory if you're asking me for my
opinion on it I don't think that Carlos
believes the values that Andrew Tate has
built an entire career espousing I do
hope that Carlos will be able to show
True Contrition and come to understand
why his actions shocked so many people
and it looks like he started to do that
although liking tweets like the ones we
showed earlier may put a little bit of a
monkey wrench in that whole situation
but overwhelmingly the reaction from the
Esports Community has actually given me
some hope like we regularly trip over
some pretty low bars but in this case
the consensus kind of seemed to be yeah
we're not cool with this the future of
Carlos and G2 remains in doubt the Tweet
liking situation might mean he's going a
little rogue but I'll keep an eye on it
whether the brand will bounce back and
how exactly Carlos will be involved in
that remains unclear for now
foreign
[Music]